the virus reacts to different
temperatures climates and surfaces the
findings confirm that the virus survives
better and colder and drier environments
and does less well in warmer and more
humid environments and then I see the
disinfectant where it knocks it out in a
minute one minute and is there way we
can do something like that by injection
inside or almost a cleaning because you
see it gets on the lungs and it does a
tremendous number along so it'd be
interesting to check this let's go live
to our US correspondent Cordelia Lynch
in Washington they've been more than
raised eyebrows at these remarks from
the president Cordy yeah absolutely I
mean are all I can summarize the
response really to there says
incredulity condemnation consternation
no one could quite believe that these
were the words coming out of the mouth
of the president time and again he said
I am NOT a scientist and then gone on to
make these almost declarative remarks
about possible cures possible solutions
to this virus which he is so desperate
to reach but many of the scientists and
the medical professionals last night
when they saw this said this is the very
worst thing that you could do to your
body certainly in terms of disinfectant
and ingesting it in any way they have
been at pains to say that that could
cause severe damage their lungs it's
dangerous as you say it is irresponsible
and in fact we've also had a statement
from the owner of the disinfectant
Dettol racket thank you sir let me just
share that with you in it they say as a
global leader in health and hygiene
products we must be clear that under
nose
siddhart disinfectant products the
administered into the human body through
ingestion ingestion or any other route
as with all products are disinfectant
and hygiene products today we the use as
intended and in line with usage
guidelines it goes on to say please read
the label and safety information we have
a responsibility in providing consumers
with access at accurate up-to-date
information as advised by leading public
health experts for this and other
myth-busting facts will actually provide
the website please visit covert - 19
facts dot-com so you see a very lengthy
statement from the company there they're
obviously deeply concerned by what the
President had to say and I think we saw
if not concern and definite discomfort
in the eyes of his scientists dr.
deborah birx a woman who has been by his
side throughout these briefings and you
saw her sort of look to the floor and
shuffle a little it was very difficult
to see the man that they are working
alongside go up and address the nation
in this way what didn't come up
it was the 50,000 death toll from
coronavirus that America now faces
Donald Trump was also pushing back on
hydroxychloroquine this was a drug that
he was touting as a possible miracle
cure when our study has come out that
suggests that in fact of the patients
that they looked at this resulted in
more deaths not less just a little note
chain on that UV light issue as well now
Donald Trump said that this is a product
of a research study that's being carried
out in Baltimore
yeah on stage last night is actually a
homeland security official he is not a
scientist but this study purports to
have put a lot of light into the virus
Donald Trump believes that means that
hopefully sunlight may help to try and
tackle coronavirus now there have been
some studies in China suggesting
something similar but critically this
research coming out of Baltimore has not
been peer reviewed that means in the
normal way that you would expect
scientific research to be dealt with
there have been no other significant
eyes on it they would certainly need
that they would also need a DEA approval
if they were to press ahead with any of
this as a kind of formal recommendations
the American public
Cornie thank you